[Música]
soy periodista soy motivadora y autora
pero sobre todas las cosas soy
orgullosamente venezolana hoy te quiero
contar por qué decirlo así con la frente
en alto con firmeza es una manera de
ejercer liderazgo quizás tú piensas que
tú nunca vas a poder ser líder por las
circunstancias que te rodean o porque no
eres lo suficientemente grande o
importante pero a diferencia de lo que
te van a decir muchas personas los
grandes líderes no nacen sino se hacen a
través del tiempo y la experiencia hoy
te voy a decir como tú puedes lograrlo
con tan solo cinco pasos
yo nací a orillas del mar caribe
cobijada bajo el ávila escuchando las
historias de quienes probablemente el
líder más grande de venezuela y para
muchos de latinoamérica simón bolívar
recuerdo que cursaba el tercer grado
cuando en mi colegio se armó la obra de
teatro de simón bolívar yo como todas
mis compañeras quería el papel
protagónico por suerte esta obra
comprendía la vida entera del libertador
entonces uno podía audicionar para
varios simón bolívar el de la
independencia del ecuador y el perú el
de la gran colombia y el que yo quería
el de la batalla de carabobo miren yo
pasé semanas en mi cuarto con una
estrellita plástica así practicando sus
batallas finalmente llamaron del colegio
a decirme que había quedado en la obra
sería un simón bolívar bueno yo fui
corriendo el día después a la cartelera
del salón donde pude leer mi parte
mariana tencio el matrimonio ese mundo
soy yo sería el simón bolívar que se
casaba con maría teresa del toro y
alayza yo llegué a mi casa desmoralizada
así arrastrando la espalda plástica era
como como esos niños que querían ser el
niño jesús en el acto de navidad y
terminaron siendo una oveja o un
pastorcito bueno como solía ser cuando
necesitaba consuelo fui hablar con mi
papá
y tú puedes crear lo que me tocó los
años me tengo que casar con una amiga
mía a mí me apena hacer eso
en ese momento mi papá me enseñó una
lección que nunca olvidaré
me dijo hija tú tienes la
responsabilidad de dar lo mejor de ti
por tu país si quizás estás haciendo un
papel que no quieres pero eres
historia venezolana
es motivo de mucho orgullo
los líderes no se hacen solo en la
guerra
y las gestas civiles son igual o quizás
más importantes que las batallas
campales
mi papá me habló de la importancia de
una ceremonia civil como es el
matrimonio como muchos aquí que me están
escuchando que están casados y algunos
divorciados también sabrán señores el
matrimonio es una gesta heróica
total yo me tomé esta elección de mi
papá muy a pecho me presenté en la
asamblea del colegio tomada en mi amiga
vestida de blanco al son de la marcha
nupcial tan tan tan y di lo mejor de mí
aquí les comparto unas fotos de ese
momento donde descubrí la primera clave
para ser líder el liderazgo puede venir
de lugares inesperados no podemos dejar
que nuestros héroes civiles estos
gigantes que han luchado incansablemente
por la paz queden bajo la sombra de los
guerreros su lugar en la patria tiene
que ser igualmente respetado y valorado
figuras como el locutor y animador renny
ottolina con su lema de yo no quiero
igualar hacia abajo
yo quiero igualar hacia arriba
el médico y ahora beato josé gregorio
hernández quien no nada más realizó
milagros pero fundó la academia nacional
de medicina el maestro josé antonio
abreu fundador del sistema de orquestas
infantiles de venezuela si los tenemos a
todos ellos y a muchos otros entonces
porque le damos tanto valor a los
guerreros pero es que si ustedes
escuchan las letras de los himnos
nacionales de muchos de nuestros países
latinoamericanos se darán cuenta a que
le asignamos valores y como eso de
alguna manera determina la idiosincrasia
de nuestros pueblos por ejemplo no queda
duda que los argentinos se sienten
especiales ustedes han escuchado el
comienzo del himno nacional argentino
va más o menos así oíd mortales el grito
sagrado o sea dios les habla el coro
continúa y los libres del mundo
responden al gran pueblo argentino salud
no van a sentirse especiales viste
el himno nacional venezolano como muchos
otros comienza en tono marcial
gloria al bravo pueblo que el yugo lanzó
por eso somos de naturaleza combativa
pero siguiendo la lección de mi papá hay
una parte civil con la que yo escojo
quedarme
seguiré el ejemplo que caracas dio
y que ejemplo estamos dando para
nuestros hijos que sembrarán nuevas
estrellas no podemos quedarnos atascados
en un pasado sangriento por muy glorioso
que parezca el liderazgo del futuro
requiere de nuevas claves nuevos
paradigmas para lograr la solidaridad y
la unión
y es una lucha tan ardua y constante
como cualquier batalla
clave 2 el líder tiene que tener la
unidad para reconocer sus errores nos
encanta etiquetar a nuestros
compatriotas y eso nos hace un pueblo
muy dividido política social
económicamente que sí es rico que si es
pobre que si es del este que si en el
oeste que será la cuarta que será la
quinta que se flaca que si es gorda por
qué ser gorda en venezuela- pecado
mortal
en lugar de ver lo que el otro puede
acortar nos cuesta mucho ponernos en los
zapatos de aquel que piensa distinto que
viene de otro estrato social
otro error común es buscar referentes
afuera y aquí yo hago un 'mea culpa'
bien grande referentes culturales
lugares paradisíacos a donde viajar yo
lo recorrido venezuela lo suficiente
conozcamos a nuestro país ya nuestra
gente para poder liderar la
clave 3
el liderazgo se expresa de viva dos con
la palabra
allí comienza todo esa es la manera de
re imaginar las circunstancias y mejorar
la realidad
y como hablamos de venezuela te has
preguntado eso mi profesora preferida de
la universidad católica andrés bello la
ministra mercedes pulido ella decía que
cuando viajaba al exterior le sorprendía
que muchos le preguntaban que porque el
venezolano usaba el adjetivo este para
referirse a su propio país no es que en
este país no hay educación y que en este
país todo el mundo roba es que en este
país todo anda mal porque hablamos de
este como si hubiese otro
la palabra puede servir para construir y
para destruir yo sé que tengo uso de
razón a mí me han dicho que yo nací en
un país que era grande pero que ahora
está en crisis literalmente el recorte
de periódico de mi álbum de bebé dice
venezuela en crisis
el escritor arturo uslar pietri decía tu
mundo es tan grande como tu vocabulario
vamos a inventar uno nuevo entonces uno
positivo para describir a venezuela
te dejo esa tarea después de que
escuches esta charla haz una lista de
adjetivos positivos a usar para cuando
te refieres a venezuela y a los
venezolanos
positivos creativos echados para
adelante tenaces resilientes dejemos de
destruirnos con la palabra y otros lo
harán también
miren yo me fui de venezuela hace poco
más de 10 años y de las cosas que más me
afectan es escuchar a otros hablar mal
de venezuela
yo sé que no lo hacen con mala intención
pero igual duele demasiado cuando te
dicen de dónde venezolanas ay qué
tragedia
y tu familia sigue allá y yo no sé cómo
la gente puede vivir allá
déjenme dejarles algo claro la crisis
venezolana es terrible
ser venezolano no lo es
yo me rehúso a inspirar lástima
seamos más que este mirar hacia abajo
que esta división este odio y la
mediocridad que ha sembrado en nosotros
la dictadura
yo no recuerdo un momento de mi vida
donde yo no haya estado plenamente
orgullosa de ser venezolana viendo lo
que construyeron mis abuelos yendo al
estadio de béisbol o bailando en las
gaitas escolares con mis amigas
nunca nunca nos avergoncemos de esto
nuestro pasaporte aunque muchos lo vean
como que no vale nada como que hay que
buscar un plan b
no hay pecado ni vergüenza en nuestra
identidad y mucho menos en nuestro
gentilicio
piensen en el liderazgo de nuestros
maestros lo que han logrado nuestros
médicos nuestros pequeños empresarios en
medio de la adversidad eso es heroico
los de apiés los caraqueños los
valencianos los maracuchos los
margariteños los llaneros los gochos
los de todos los días
esos son los héroes como mi papá
mi papá fundó una arepera funcionaba 24
horas al día 7 días a la semana en
caracas donde allí se le atendía a gente
de distintas profesiones de distintas
clases sociales que confluyen allí para
compartir lo más simple pero lo más
simbólico de nuestra tierra una arepa
y yo me acuerdo de mi papá marchando por
venezuela en cada oportunidad cuando ya
el cuerpo le dolía cuando había perdido
la esperanza cuando el país le dolía
demasiado pero ahí estaba él apostando
por venezuela siempre
y eso me lleva a decirte hoy que el
liderazgo no está ausente de dolor ni
sufrimiento es directamente proporcional
a ello aquellos que hemos sobrevivido
ambientes hostiles estamos mucho más
preparados para enfrentar cualquier reto
pero eso me lleva al punto 4 de
liderazgo
dejemos de esperar al líder mesiánico
que va a venir a resolver nos los
problemas
rechacemos a aquellos que juegan con las
esperanzas de nuestro pueblo y sobre
todo no esperemos las soluciones
extranjeras
dos de las coberturas que a mí más me
han impactado como periodistas fueron
cubrir la muerte de hugo chávez y la de
fidel castro porque porque yo pude
hablar con gente verlos a los ojos gente
que esperaba un cambio de la noche a la
mañana y pronto se dieron cuenta que
nada iba a cambiar porque el verdadero
cambio viene de adentro porque un país
se solidifica con unión y con trabajo el
verdadero líder no es el que tiene
superpoderes ni el que está esperando a
que los salven
es el que se cae y se levanta todos los
días es el que pone su granito de arena
desde donde esté desde su ámbito desde
su tierra no desde su industria
aquí trazo una pincelada si se quiere
desde aquel acto en el colegio donde
protagoniza al simón bolívar civil a mi
trabajo hoy como periodista como
conferencista y autora yo lleve esa
elección de mi papá de alguna manera de
traducir la realidad venezolana a otros
públicos con mis reportajes en inglés o
internacionalmente escribió un libro en
dos idiomas perfectamente tú donde hable
de mi infancia en venezuela donde
coloque un mapa de nuestro país una
bandera de venezuela para aquellos
lectores que no la conocen
aquí llegó el punto 5 el más importante
el llamado a la acción
asume la responsabilidad de devolverle
al país aún desde afuera desde donde
estés asume la
eleva a otros venezolanos eso es
liderazgo
dejemos de pisar nos dejemos de medirnos
por lo que hay nuestras cuentas de banco
por las tallas y marcas de nuestra ropa
rescatemos el orgullo de la
venezolanidad
fue el último deseo de mi papá
y por más que que me dolió su partida
física
me queda que cuando el timón rompió su
vela enterramos su cuerpo cerca del mar
en venezuela'
honrando a álvaro atención atención mi
papi
para quien la mejor descripción de sí
mismo era sencillamente una palabra
venezolano
por él por él yo corrijo la mirada de
lástima por él yo dejo de que nos llamen
los pobrecitos dignos de un lo siento
mucho no por él yo pongo la frente en
alto y firme y sonora digo si soy
orgullosamente venezolana
y eso no significa que le estoy haciendo
que pongan la otra mejilla no se
equivoque por venezuela vamos a luchar
con garras
pero elevando nos y demostrándole al
mundo con nuestro trabajo de que estamos
hechos los venezolanos
termino como una invitación un referente
a ese pasado con el que si elijo
quedarme unida con lazos que el cielo
formó la américa toda
existen nación
si eres latinoamericano si hablas
español me estás escuchando hoy fomenta
la unidad ayuda a tus hermanos que
probablemente están pasando por algo que
tu país también atravesó
antes venezuela recibía inmigrantes de
todas partes del mundo de naciones en
caos ahora nos ha tocado ser esos
inmigrantes es una elección difícil de
aprender y de aceptar
quizás el día de mañana eres tú quien
necesite buscar refugio en otras tierras
así que extiende nos la mano sin juzgar
y ayúdanos pero sin ofrecernos lástima o
limosna corremos las divisiones mentales
y re imaginemos un mapa de una
latinoamérica unida invencible y digna
de ser nombrada en cualquier parte del
mundo como el mejor ejemplo de liderazgo
un liderazgo que hoy comienza contigo
muchas gracias